[Música]
qué alegría estar con todos ustedes
amigos qué alegría
y qué alegría que existan hombres con
hombres pensadores visionarios hombres
de acción científicos soñadores pero
también materializa dores de sus sueños
y amigos de la jerarquía del roberto
sasso querido amigo
muy bien amigos vamos a hablar hoy sobre
dos temas vamos a hablar sobre música y
después vamos a hablar sobre el fútbol a
petición de roberto sasso y cuando hablo
del fútbol no me refiero a la porquería
de saprissa de ayer
no y eso que soy saprissista pero yo me
resiento cuando mi equipo me trata mal
yo me re ciento no les aguantó nada nada
no me gusta que me que me humillen
porque la gente a mí me vacila como
saben que yo eso sea prezista me vacilan
entonces es una cosa que no apreció
cuando me hacen lucir tan mal
y amigos manuel maría gutiérrez compuso
el himno nacional en 1956 pero también
compuso el que es nuestro segundo himno
nacional del patrón austral zen se es a
la compuso en 1862 pero el país tiene
161 años de estar oyendo una versión
adulterada falsa pervertida corrompida
espuria de lo que era la verdadera
original patriótica nacional don manuel
maría gutiérrez que era un gran soldado
del ejército nacional y que luchó contra
hull louis los filibusteros e hizo un
acto de heroísmo que es superior más
espectacular y más más increíble que el
de juan santamaría pero eso no tenemos
tiempo para contárselos hoy los voy a
dejar con la con la duda y el año
entrante si roberto me invita de nuevo
les cuento en qué consistió ese gran
acto de heroísmo de manuel maría
gutiérrez que participó en la gran
batalla la gran batalla contra los
filibusteros
con un acto extraordinario
extraordinario como de película
hollywoodense tenía que ser músico
verdad
de manera que escribió una patriótica
era una marcha militar era música
exaltante exultante estimulante era
música para hacer marcha da para
desfiles para mandar a los soldados al
campo de batalla no el valsecito lento
pegajoso siguen ciro para do cansino
viscoso cursi en que yo no sé quién en
qué momento lo transformó tos voy a
autocar para ustedes y esto es una
primicia esto es un estreno para el país
por primera vez en 161 años ted ex va a
oír vamos a oír la patriótica como la
escribió don manuel maría gotera es la
versión original la que algún compositor
o director músico debería retomar por
respeto al autor
a algunos les va a gustar
gracias gracias amigos gracias
gracias algunos les va a gustar a otros
no les va a gustar con seguridad todos
los va a descontar pero es así como
manuel maria quería que sonara la
patriótica así y no como suena hoy en
día
[Música]
ah
e
[Música]
ah
ahí ven ustedes esta es otra cosa es
otra cosa es otra cosa de esto yo no sé
en qué momento está viva se estimulante
marcha se convirtió en
[Música]
no no no no no entiendo como no entiendo
cómo pero en eso terminamos es
imperativo que algún músico nacional
rearreglo y restaure y restituye esa
pieza patrimonial nuestra hermosa al
ritmo de marca yo creo que funciona muy
bien al ritmo de marcha muy bien muy es
otra cosa pero funciona muy bien amigos
pasamos al fútbol
así es mi vida así es mi vida pero no a
cualquier fútbol al mejor fútbol que
jamás se ha visto sobre la faz del
planeta al equipo por antonomasia el
equipo absoluto el mejor equipo del
siglo 20 había un técnico brasileño que
se llamaba mario lobos a carlos le
decían for me guiña hormiguita por lo
minucioso que era en su forma de
trabajar vive todavía está muy viejo y
mario lobo zagalo se estaba preparando
para el mundial de fútbol y 1970 que fue
un primero que fue transmitido en vivo
por unos satélites que se amaban telstar
de hechos y le pusieron nombre a la bola
que se usaba la pelota del star fue el
primero en ser transmitido en vivo a
todo el mundo al vivo ya todo color en
costa rica yo recuerdo estar en mi casa
yo tenía 7 años de edad
estamos en 1970 estaba con mi papá y
estábamos sentados en una especie de
patio citó de luz interior y mi papá
diciéndome viene mire papito a lo que
está pasando ahí en la tele estos
señores jugando fútbol están
en este preciso momento 2000 km allá al
norte en mexico para que vea lo
extraordinaria que es la tecnología me
decía yo a mí eso me deslumbraba
así de viejo soy eso me erizaba a mí me
fascinaba a mí me dije era
extraordinario para mí verdad hoy en día
es tan banal es tan trivial que no nos
damos cuenta del milagro que supone que
se esté jugando un partido en madrid a
8.000 millas de distancia uno se dará
por medio y nosotros lo estamos viendo
en vivo pero en el 70 era vídeo era una
gran cosa que sucedía entonces lo que
haga lo hizo fue esto
y en lo cuento porque es un hecho
futbolístico que también es un paradigma
de vida sacarlo se dijo quiero tener en
mi equipo a los cinco mejores dieces a
los cinco mejores números 10 del
campeonato brasileño el jugador que
juega con la camiseta del 10 es el
mediocampista de creación el más
habilidoso el líder el que el que
arranca con balón controlado desde el
mediocampo llega al área pone el último
pase de gol central o dribla anota goles
es ese es el eje del ataque tiene que
hacer un crack tiene que ser muy
habilidoso tiene que ser rápido
inteligente por algo es el 10 verdad
quienes han sido 10 es pelé maradona
platini y si dan todos el ronaldinho no
sólo van a cualquier el 10 entonces yo
quiero tener a cinco dieces en mi
selección lo cual era una extravagancia
ligero pero mario estás loco quién va a
defender quién va a ser de volante de
contención quién
las segundas pelotas las pelotas
divididas vas a tener un equipo que es
como un macro céfalo con una cabeza
enorme y un cuerpito chiquitillo quien
se va a quedar atrás que avanza circo
pues no puedes jugar y 510 es que los
vas a poner uno encima del otro así como
un tótem como cómo vas a acomodar a tres
jugadores que juegan en la misma
posición sacarlos de un 1 yo quiero a
mis cinco dieces yo quiero mis cinco
dieces quiero un equipo o sea
ultraofensivo y si tal vez tengamos una
defensa medio blanda pero mi política es
esta señores pero nos hacen un gol
hacemos dos si no meten dos hacemos tres
y finalmente 100 hacemos 101 y es así
como voy a jugar y el gesto del saga lo
fue tan bello hay tal intrepidez tal
audacia tal romanticismo saga lo fue el
último romántico del fútbol mundial el
jugador el técnico que no jugó el fútbol
con criterio pragmático real
es tan mezquino avaro conservador
amarretes de meter a gente atrás y tira
el pelotazo un pobre [ __ ] que hay más
o menos suelo ahí como una milpa 50
metros no no no no si el estilo el
estilo óscar ramírez
no nos haga lo quería cinco números
dieces y los cinco los tenía quería a
los cinco mejores jugadores de brasil
aunque jugaban en la misma posición los
quería tener en el equipo y esos
jugadores eran pelé queden 10 del santos
rivelino que era el 10 de corinthians
gerson que el 10 de sao paulo jairzinho
que era el 10 de botafogo donde venía de
sustituir a garrincha que estaba en
total decadencia por el alcoholismo y a
tostao queda el 10 de cruzeiro y los
puso juntos los acomodó como pudo puso
ayer son en el puro centro rivelino como
era absurdo lo tiró a la izquierda y al
diseño como era derecho lo tiró a la
derecha ató a tostado lo puso del número
9 y apele le dijo usted es el rey
muévase por donde dé la gana métase a la
defensa juega por las bandas soy yo a
usted yo no le tengo que dar usted es el
rey y está usted no le tengo que dar
indicaciones
el resultado amigos fue un fútbol de una
belleza
de una belleza tal y ganaron el
campeonato y en el hotel de las palmeras
donde estaban en río de janeiro saga lo
puso la mano sobre la mesa y dijo quiero
que me pongan ustedes cinco mil cinco
escogidos vi cinco dieces mis cinco
astros pongan la mano todos unos sobre
la otra
vamos a jugar esto seremos el primer
equipo en llegar a mexico y seremos el
último en dejar méxico
vamos a ganar el campeonato vamos a
jugar el fútbol más bello que el mundo
ha visto no vamos a cometer faules no
vamos a protestar decisiones arbitrales
no vamos a hacer berrinches ni ataques
de violencia vamos a apreciar el fútbol
más bello y más ofensivo y más
propositivo que el mundo ha visto y lo
fue y lo fue y la historia recuerda ese
brasil de 1970 como el mejor equipo de
todos los tiempos entonces quiero tocar
una pieza de bici que se llama fuego de
artificio
que no tiene nada que ver con sacarlo
pero ciertamente es una pieza muy
difícil donde el tenista tiene que
tomarse muchos riesgos de hecho me han
pasado cosas divertidas es un preludio
de belvís y fuegos de artificio soledad
difícil lo único que me ha pasado nunca
es que me salgan chispas del piano eso
eso no lo ha logrado nunca pero pero no
dejó de soñar que algún día sea capaz de
ese prodigio esto para ponerlo en
conjunción con el gesto de sagan por el
fútbol deshaga lo que era un fútbol de
fuego de artificio era espectacular
sacaba los ojos embelesaba es que no era
fútbol amigos era era coreografía era
danza era la belleza del movimiento eras
eras fútbol en el límite del arte era
fútbol arte era 'jogo bonito' eso es lo
que quiero decirles más que pateadores
de bola esos 3 pelé rivelino todo está
oyendo en el sillón eran bailarines eran
grupos porque yo los veo como si fueran
nureyev y eran eran poetas del balón es
otro concepto de lo que tenemos hoy en
día fuegos de artificio de bici
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
bueno
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
e
[Música]
hola
ah
[Música]
gracias
petras
[Música]